[Music]
listen carefully
watch learn mortal kombat has begun
there's a war coming we need to fight
before it's too late
mortal kombat has started as this very
simple 8-bit fighting game
that was revolutionary at the time i
liked the idea that we could bring
these characters to a level that hadn't
really been seen before
in the games for fighting this brutal
fight
and so you've got to hire these people
that have that ability absolutely
the fight scene's so epic
it's mind-blowing what they do really
the fatalities are sickeningly violent
flawless victory but we all knew that we
needed to cast some really amazing
talented
people to make it feel real
lewis tan is an incredible athlete
incredible fighter
a guy worked so hard was just
unbelievable
he just did not stop
i come from a fighting background real
martial arts to me is very similar to
acting because it's all about expression
there's so much fighting in this movie
that a lot of times after
shooting one fight
we need to practice for some other fight
that's going to take place because we
just don't have
enough time
i knew joe was going to be sub-zero from
day one
joe's got that pure athleticism
i made the mistake of watching the raid
a couple nights before we fought i go i
gotta fight this dude
i gotta fight i gotta fight that dude
joe was faster than everyone joe was too
fast
that was so fast i had to ask him to
slow it down for the camera it was like
two guys
that's ever happened to joe taslim and
bruce lee
a fight scene and a drama scene they are
the same in a drama you have the lines
but in a fight
it's just the agony struggle the pain
those are our lines
you cast for what's in their brain what
they've learned over the years
especially with someone like martial art
it's impossible to bring someone up to
his level quickly that's just not going
to happen
the same goes for hiroyuki sonata they
both have a very similar set of
qualities in that they have a presence
they have a look about them
[Music]
we try to make a contrast between
sub-zero and scorpio a little
mixture between game and authentic
japanese style
watching those two on set was one of the
great privileges i'll ever have in my
life
[Music]
first learned about this seven years ago
on a mission in brazil
to capture a wanted fugitive
when we got there it tore through our
unit in seconds
the target has superhuman abilities
[Applause]
[Music]
it had the same marking you do cole
it's a birthmark what do you mean he was
born with it
it's not a birthmark cole means you've
been chosen
throughout history different cultures
all over the world
reference a great tournament
world champions that dragon marking
i think it's an invitation to fight for
something known
[Applause]
as mortal kombat
these are your champions i'm sonya
that's kano i'm luke
thanks jax
[Applause]
no matter how many of my people you put
in the ground
we will not fail kill them
i am zero
get over here
you [ __ ] beauty
you